back to work after having her baby today
was about getting back to core brand
Megan surrounded by women launching a
fashion range for women with the charity
supporting women smart works helps the
long-term unemployed dressing them for
job interviews and supporting them
through the process female empowerment
longer cause close to her heart as women
it is a hundred percent our
responsibility I think to support and
uplift each other to champion each other
as we aim to succeed to not set each
other set each other up for failure a
veiled dig perhaps for her critics it's
not been an easy summer for the Sussex
ah's as well as being criticized for
taking a number of private jets megan
was called highbrow and overly political
when she guest edited vogue
while many deem the criticism unfair
experts say there's a need to take back
control of the narrative I think there's
a little bit of work to do I think
things like this are great steps and I
think she's worked very hard to make
sure this is very concise and the work
that they do is really strong in the
messaging it's really strong meanwhile
today Harry was also out promoting a
cause close to his heart spanking
shutting his own car door a small break
of royal protocol but regaining
relatability in the eyes of the public
may be hard
you know but she's kind of traveled a
lot and been there a lot and maybe at
the end of the day she might ever better
because she keeps to herself and does
her own thing doesn't she
they might Harry she needs to do quite a
lot more where the public see I think
it's an amazing thing that she's doing I
don't think it's my bro
she is helping people for any new mum
priorities do change the real work
perhaps still at home Helen Anne Smith
Sky News